In 1809, Captain Robert Barclay Allardice
made a bet with one of his pedestrian rivals,
Sir James Webster-Wedderburn, that he could
walk 1,000 miles (about 1,609 kilometers)
in 1,000 hours.
The wager?
1,000 guineas.
To get around the major problem of needing
to rest, Barclay figured if he walked back
to back miles–a mile at the end of one hour
and another at the beginning of the next–and
repeated this strategy throughout the race,
he would be able to rest in approximately
90 minute intervals throughout the near 42
day long race.
It worked.
He completed the walk on July 12, 1809, 42
days after it commenced.
The 1,000 miles in 1,000 hours walking feat
became widely known as the “Barclay Match”.
While any sort of race involving simply walking
at a leisurely pace may sound easy, walking
1,000 miles in 1,000 consecutive hours is
anything but.
Beyond the physical toll on the body, the
lack of consistent prolonged sleep over a
six-week period and the lack of doing anything
but walk around in circles takes a major mental
toll.
After Barclay, many pedestrians attempted
the same feat of feet and failed, but it wasn’t
until a female Australian attempted the Barclay
Match and failed that the opportunity unfolded
for another women to make history.
Due to the ideology of this era that women
were extremely frail, they were strongly urged
(and sometimes forced) to not partake in strenuous
activity such as sporting competitions.
For instance, 17 year old Yankee minor leaguer
Jackie Mitchell once struck out Babe Ruth
and Lou Gehrig back to back on just seven
pitches, five of them of the swing and miss
variety; the next day, she was banned from
major and minor league baseball by commissioner
Kenesaw Mountain Landis who stated his reason
for doing so was because baseball was “too
strenuous” for women.
(This purported frailty hadn’t stopped Lizzie
“The Queen of Baseball” Murphy from enjoying
an extremely lucrative 23 year career as a
professional baseball player, during which
she became the first person, man or woman,
to play for both the National League and American
League All Star teams.)
In any event, long before the Queen of Baseball
was making a laughingstock of the idea of
women being too “delicate” to play sports,
in 1864, Emma Sharp heard about the aforementioned
Australian woman’s failed attempt at the
Barclay Match.
Mrs. Sharp, who was then in her early thirties,
subsequently declared to her husband, John,
that she thought she could do it.
John was reportedly not so enthusiastic, stating
that walking 1,000 miles was hardly an appropriate
task for a woman to undertake.
Undeterred and despite that she’d not actually
trained for the event at all, Emma proceeded
with her conviction and started making plans
for the event.
She was fortunate enough to enlist the help
of the landlord of the Quarry Gap Hotel, at
Laisterdyke, England, who enthusiastically
offered up the grounds attached to his hotel
as the location of the course.
In exchange, he would receive a percentage
of the money earned from ticket sales, and
no doubt do great business from all the spectators.
While the fact that anyone would pay to see
someone walking around in circles for days
on end may seem strange to us, at the time,
competitive walking, or pedestrianism, was
one of the most popular spectator sports in
the Western world, with certain matches drawing
tens of thousands of spectators.
Yes, before the internet and TV, our forebears
found watching people walk in circles for
hours on end an ideal excuse to get together
and socialize, in some respects not too dissimilar
from NASCAR, but without the occasional flaming
crashes.
As for Sharp’s walk, it was likely to draw
bigger crowds than most given that she was
a woman attempting a physical feat that most
of her compatriots of the male persuasion
couldn’t do.
To make the whole thing even more scandalous
in the eyes of contemporaries, Emma decided
to dress like a man for the event, a sensible
choice given the typical garb of Victorian
era women.
And so it was that on September 17, 1864,
Emma Sharp took the first step of her 1,000
mile venture.
She took the same approach as Captain Barclay
by walking a roped off course of 120 yards
for 30 minutes at a time, which was equivalent
to about two miles, before taking a 90-minute
break.
She would continue this routine for six weeks
straight, walking day and night, until she
completed her last mile.
As expected, since no woman had ever successfully
completed this journey, and few men, Emma’s
progress was widely reported in the newspapers
and watched closely by supporters and critics
alike, with tens of thousands of people turning
up at various times to watch her put one foot
in front of the other again and again.
As was popular with all such pedestrian events,
many started making bets as to whether or
not she would actually be able to finish.
With the odds heavily against her at first,
as the days wore on and it began to look like
she might actually do it, malicious attempts
to thwart her progress began.
Beyond near constant jeering to break her
spirit, about a week before she was scheduled
to finish the 1,000 miles, unidentified individuals
attacked her with chloroform to rough her
up a bit, hoping this would inspire her to
quit.
She didn’t.
Others threw burning embers in her path, some
tried to drug her food, and still others simply
resorted to trying to trip her at random times.
As things escalated, for her protection, eighteen
police officers disguised as working citizens
were assigned to her on the final days of
the race.
In addition to that, during the night, a helpful
citizen walked in front of her with a loaded
rifle.
Emma also walked the final two days with a
pistol, which she had to fire in warning a
reported 27 times in total to ward off unruly
spectators.
On October 29, 1864, at approximately 5:15
a.m., Emma Sharp became the first woman to
complete the Barclay Challenge.
Despite the general belief that women were
too frail for such physical activity and despite
her complete lack of training, the only major
physical issue she experienced during the
walk was painfully swollen ankles in the early
going, but the problem ultimately went away
as the days went on.
Over the course of the six straight weeks
she walked, it was estimated that a total
of over 100,000 people turned up at one point
or another, with about 25,000 being present
to watch her cross the finish line.
Despite the fact that the locals celebrated
Emma’s success by organizing a band to play
on her final day and roasting an ox in her
honor, Emma’s husband reportedly hid in
the pub, embarrassed by his wife’s antics.
He got over his shame pretty quickly, however,
using the substantial funds she earned from
ticket sales to quit his job at the Bowling
Iron Works and open a rug making business.